jeremiah jones field agronomist with
pioneer kelly robertson granular csa
with precision crop services
so kelly you and i have been talking the
last three or four weeks about some
observations that we're seeing out in
the fields yeah we're starting to see a
lot of problems crop up as a result of
the wet spring we've had
so we've been talking about uneven
stands we're seeing in corn and soybeans
both and a lot of those uneven stands
first of all get attributed back to
tillage done when it was too wet so
we're starting to see a lot of
the results of tillage done wet
restricted layers caused by tillage
compaction and whatnot yes
so
talking about that we're seeing
restricted root growth so we're seeing a
lot of nutrient deficiencies showing up
you know sulfur or nitrogen
so in addition to the tillage that was
done too i had a lot of
corn and soybeans were planted into wet
conditions so we've got sidewall
compaction so we've got restricted root
growth
and as a result of that and the tillage
uh the plants are just not able to get
to the nutrients that are there
so we we sidewalled in our nitrogen we
got sidewall compaction there
yeah we're seeing a lot of fields with
the pre-plant anhydrous that you can you
can still see the the application pass
at an angle through the field
when you you can literally in some
fields even after the anhydrous was
applied and tillage was done you can
still see
where the anhydrous toolbar went through
the field when you dig into those areas
what you're finding is a very restricted
sidewall compacted knife slot and so you
see yellow plants that have a restricted
root that can't get to the nitrogen and
then you're seeing nitrogen still
staying in that slot
so by no means is this um
the world ended but so what are we going
to do about these problems well the the
first problem is is going to be that
there's going to be people that are
going to come and tell you that you need
to apply more nitrogen or that you need
to put a foliar on to correct a nutrient
deficiency or do something with an input
to try to fix this and the first thing
we want to recognize is we're not going
to fix these problems with any more of
something so adding more of a chemical
or a fertilizer or anything is not going
to fix a mechanical issue that we
created early in the season
i know that in some of your updates i
received from him you got a good
statement it says what is go yeah a goal
so that's our theme this year gold get
out and look
most problems can be avoided if you get
out of the tractor cab get out in the
field look at the tillage tool look at
the soil look at the planter and not
rely on a monitor or what you're seeing
six feet above the ground in a glass
bubble so goal get out and look and i
would encourage you when you see these
areas in the fields get out look at them
look at imagery and if you have any
questions please reach out to your local
pioneer team
that concludes this pioneer agronomy
video podcast visit our page on
pioneer.com and follow us on twitter and
facebook for more agronomy insights